comme chaque matin depuis le 13 juillet
- m'aidera yens hamzaoui passe en revue
son armée de blouses blanches
un point quotidien pour évaluer la
situation dans ce gymnase municipal
transformer en unité qu vide
face à la recrudescence des cas positifs
à la saturation des hôpitaux au manque
de moyens à l'inaction du gouvernement
le jeune maire de la commune des haras
au sud de tunis s'est lancé un défi
celui de sauver ses administrés de cette
épidémie meurtrière
nous sommes ici dans un gymnase dédiée
au basket ball le sport emblématique de
notre ville aujourd'hui au vu de la
situation dans le pays nous l'avons
transformé en hôpital de campagne
ici nous ne sommes pas en marge de la
crise sanitaire que traverse tunis dans
tout le pays la situation est
inquiétante des hôpitaux et des
cliniques saturés des patients la
recherche de concentrateurs d'oxygène
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas rester les bras croisés et
qu'une solution devait être trouvée
cette solution fut la transformation de
cet espace
nous avons aujourd'hui 20 lits équipé de
tout le nécessaire à la prise en charge
des patients
les réseaux sociaux moi mes draps yens
hamzaoui en a fait son fer de lance
un moyen efficace pour rassembler les
forces vives de sa commune et j'ai
publié une vidéo pour alerter de la
situation que nous traversions afin que
la solidarité s'organise pour sauver
notre commune en sept jours tout était
bouclé l'appel a été lancé lundi le
samedi d'après nous étions opérationnel
tout le monde ya participé
les hommes d'affaires les commerçants
les artisans les vendeurs de légumes
même nos citoyens au chômage ont voulu
aider certains ont pu offrir des vies et
d'autre du matériel médical et d'autre
des concentrateurs d'oxygène un pour que
naisse cet endroit parmi ces âmes
charitables man l infirmière dans le
privé n'a pas hésité une seconde
comme tous les autres bénévoles c'est un
devoir citoyen pour elle de venir en
aide à son pays dans cette sombre
période
je suis infirmière et c'est mon travail
je n'ai aucune raison d'avoir peur de
prêter main-forte bien au contraire
c'est un devoir pour chacun des des
soupirs
après c'est vrai qu'il ya une différence
entre travailler dans le privé et dans
le public ou le manque de moyens est
flagrant en tant qu'infirmière je peux
faire des sacrifices notamment sur mon
équipement de protection
mais lorsque vous manqué d'oxygène ou de
médicaments pour sauver des vies
la différence est importante et cette
précarité des hôpitaux publics
amina en a fait les frais à 70 ans elle
s'est décrite comme rescapées du service
public
après un passage de quelques jours à
l'hôpital public de ben arous
elle a été accueillie ici ou sa santé
s'est rapidement améliorée j'ai passé
dix jours à l'hôpital et j'ai failli
mourir
la situation là bas était catastrophique
j'ai été jeté dans un couloir là bas si
vous avez des relations entre être
autrement
sinon vous n'avez que dieu j'ai passé
dix jours sur une chaise c'est alors
qu'on a contacté le maire de cette
commune
il a dit ramener là et ses soins seront
couverts que dieu le bénisse
ça fait maintenant presque dix jours que
je suis ici je suis arrivé dans une
situation critique et aujourd'hui je
vais beaucoup mieux
le succès de cette opération n'a pas été
sans embûches alors que tout était
opérationnel le maire s'est heurtée à la
lenteur de l'administration tunisienne
prétextant un problème de procédure le
ministère de la santé n'a finalement
permis à mohamed ryan hamzaoui d'ouvrir
son unité qui après des jours d'attentes
aujourd'hui face à la réussite de son
projet il souhaite aller plus loin à
savoir la vaccination massive et rapide
de sa population
on m'a dit qu'il y avait des procédures
à respecter
nous avions respecté ces procédures nous
ne souhaitions pas enfreindre la loi
mais nous observions la situation sous
un autre angle
la situation était grave et nous
n'avions pas de temps à perdre tout
devait être fait en parallèle et c'est
ce qui s'est passé nous avons tout
préparé en amont pour être opérationnel
dès l'aval des autorités depuis le début
de cette opération plus d'une
cinquantaine de patients sont passés par
cette unité qu'ovide grâce à la
générosité des donateurs matériel
oxygène équipements ne manquent pas pour
permettre 45 médecins et infirmières
bénévoles de mener à bien leur mission
initiative citoyenne qui a donné des
idées à d'autres élus qui souhaiteraient
voir des projets similaires éclore dans
leur commune